we want to establish an amazing masjid
for the sake of allah in the country of
norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of allah subhana salaam
alaikum brothers and sisters and dear
friends something amazing happened it
amazed me so much i'm so happy that i
saw this i'm so happy that i saw it from
this community as well which i have no
doubt no this is how they actually feel
about about ilhan omar but to see in
real life is something else let's watch
this video for ourselves and see how she
got humiliated if you guys remember my
old video what did i say
that if you try to please the creation
at the cost of this pleasure of the
creator neither will the creation behave
neither would allah behave with you
watch this video how she gets viewed in
the concert of a famous somali thing
called sultan something along those
lines
watch how the somali community reacted
and rightly so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i mean in somali they say
i mean does this woman have no shame
does this woman have no shame i mean you
don't even have any nares mercy to your
husband standing there and like a
mesquite
what is wrong with you
this is one you know what's beautiful
about this very this
i'm not gonna say it's concert uh
because obviously we believe it's haram
uh but besides that what i heard was
that there was brothers who was given
tawa for the somali the people not to go
to the concerts right this one i mean
they're telling that you know people not
to go to concerts
now this is very interesting because at
the door we have muslims who are
practicing who are telling the other
muslims not to go in then you have the
general you know i want to say the
general but you have uh ten thousand i
think about ten thousand muslims uh
somali muslims who are in the concert
don't worry somebody's understanding
somalia somali i understand
they are there and then you have ilhan
so you have ilhan you have the somali uh
people in the concert youngsters whoever
maybe and then you have this maybe the
somali brothers who are in the front
door and that will tell not to come in
you know what's very interesting here
ilhan omar is someone who has made
istahlal meaning he's she's made
something which is haram
halal and some people don't take it over
rightly so now what is very amazing and
beautiful is that the crowd now you
think brother ali why are you calling
the crowd beautiful amazing when they
listen to a concert free mix and all
this kind of stuff let's put that to a
site we understand that's a sin they
know that you know why do you know what
is really amazing about this
the fact that even though they're at the
concert even though they know what
they're doing is a sin
when they come across somebody who is
violating the laws of allah on a level
where she's literally
at the cost of this pleasure of allah
these people even though they're sinning
this is what is so very crucial in islam
even though they're sinning they do not
go to a level where they acknowledge
what they're doing as a sin but the
person opposite them is so vile
so vile in their eyes even though
they're sinning because they are looking
and saying you you who support the lgbqt
and all this kind of stuff except you've
sold your religion at least the people
in that crowd the audience have a love
for allah this message now you're going
to be thinking how could it be
how could you come and say they love
allah and his messenger for them to be
that woman of that crowd show me they
love allah and his messenger even though
they're sinning why
because we have the companion of the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him and
many many who would drink alcohol he
took for uh part in the battle of badr
the battle of uh
but he used to have a habit of drinking
alcohol in front of the message of allah
can you imagine in the in front of the
messenger of allah yeah what what
happened and some of the companies came
and cursed him said may allah curse you
the mr allah stopped him no don't say
that to him
for indeed he loves allah his messenger
and he used to get punished he used to
get frogged in public
loving allah and his messenger brothers
and sisters even when they're committing
sin shows that there's hope and iman in
one's heart
but for someone like iran omar who goes
out and supports a community a group of
people who we don't want any harm to but
their way of life is absolutely opposed
to what we
live by is the problem so know that this
thing this the distinguishing markers
between ill and omar and the people in
the crowd even though they're both
sinning one's sin is to a degree of
literally kuffar and one is you know
what we are sinning but repenting we
know what we're doing is wrong where the
other one is no i don't acknowledge what
i'm doing is wrong and i'll go i guess
i'll learn this messenger
subhan allah wallahi what a reminder and
she got booed rightly so if i was in
that crowd i don't think i would have
been but i would build her myself
inshallah brothers and sisters that's
all i'm going to say till next time
assalamualaikum this brought corners to
my eyes for her to be humiliated like
that from the somali community may allah
bless somali community they are known
for for their love for the quran and for
the deen may allah keep them firm
inshallah till next time
islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a sadaqa jared for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to allah through your donation
you want to shut up in the world click
the link and donate what you can